alright I wasn't going to do this
because a lot has already been said
about prometheus which I just saw but
I'm so angry that I can't resist you
know we deserve better that's the thing
we deserve better a few years ago I went
to the Whitney Biennial it's a an
exhibition of Modern Art at the Whitney
in New York and I came away thinking
that you could categorize modern art
into three broad groups you'd have you
know genius stuff that was great and
you'd have poorly executed crap which
would be just what it sounds like and
then you could have well-executed crap
which would be like something that
didn't invoke maybe the emotional
response that the artist was hoping for
but but had something about it that was
stylistically or technically that made
you think well I ok that's sort of mean
it doesn't it's not getting past my eyes
but it's sort of neat but I think maybe
science fiction fans have a fourth
category which is a poorly executed
genius and what I mean by that is why
else would we watch Doctor Who right I
mean here's a show that in the old days
the sets wobbled and the monsters were
clearly guys in rubber suits or in trash
cans and and the characters were great
right and the stories were cool and we
watch them we didn't care about the
special effects part we were watching
them for the actual science fiction part
I don't know where to go Prometheus in
this you know I I think it may be poorly
executed no this is well-executed crap
and here's what I mean by that I had a
conversation with a friend in the office
a few months ago trying to figure out
the difference between science fiction
and horror was he's a big horror fan of
big science fiction fan and we came to
think that maybe in a horror movie all
the characters can make every decision
right can do everything correctly and
they still get killed at the end and in
science fiction if you make all the
right decisions you solve the problem
you get out alive prometheus is
something different right the equivalent
in prometheus is if you had a romantic
comedy where you had the obligatory
drunk best friend and then
somewhere between the second act and the
third
fact that person becomes a priest you
just wouldn't buy it you wouldn't sit
still for it you'd be enraged you were
romantic comedy fan that's how I feel
about the decisions the characters made
him Prometheus they did not make sense
and that really bothers me in science
fiction now the fact is that about a
year ago almost exactly a year ago Damon
Lindelof was one of the writers on the
movie and char least there was one of
the stars sat in a press conference at
comic-con and you know were joking with
each other they seem like really cool
people and they promised that this movie
was going to be awesome and i bought it
i buy it every time i bought it even in
the trailers from prometheus that gave
away the entire movie except for how
stupid it was this is on us you know
transformers is our fault prometheus is
our fault we don't get the movies we
need we get the movies we deserve and
that said I'm still so excited for the
dark knight rises I fall for this every
time every time sue me I'm an optimist